das video gleich losgeht habe eine ganz
kurze bitte an euch und über 55 prozent
kein abonnent von meinem kanal also
unter dem wir gern auf abonnieren ist
kostenlos und verpasst keine videos mehr
also ich bin dabei mein name ist luca
und herzlich willkommen wir heute zu
einer neuen episode trägt schlossherr
ich würde sagen der staat ist sinngemäß
wieder mit den besten tipp topp der
woche
[Musik]
das ist wirklich wolle die content
ja und damit herzlich willkommen zu
einer neuen episode
[Musik]
hier meine damen und herren seht ihr die
besten der besten ticks auf user am
anfang haben lassen
warum
existiert main kanal eigentlich fühlt
sich sagen meine lieben freunde aber das
ist die wahrheit
ja
das bin ich während der quarantäne
gerade
[Musik]
was
ich dachte erst er deswegen mit einem
kumpel gemacht hat und seiner hand
irgendwie gar nicht da ist und sondern
das ist die hand von den kollegen aber
wir schauen uns das ganz normal an also
achtet genau auf seine hand
franz
das ist das was so gut wie meinte doch
[Musik]
einfach mal im fahrstuhl thissen das ist
okay das ist schumi wie orange
diese katze
als sandra lukas ob ich weiß eigentlich
hätten wir dort ein anderes wort gehört
alle unter euch die selber aktiv fertig
sind kennen glaube ich auch dieses tik
tok video allerdings habe ich durch
lukas shop eingefügt denn morgen von 0
uhr bis 24 uhr also den komplett
mittwoch lange sind alle produkte in
meinem shop runter gesetzt und alle
erlöse die wir aufgrund von verkäufen
machen werden gespendet an die kölner
tafel die haben es gerade in den
aktuellen zeiten nötig sage ich mal
von daher wenig etwas bestellen möchte
in meinem shop und nicht mich
unterstützen möchte sondern die tafel
köln und zudem noch geld sparen wollte
aufgrund von prozenten die wir auf jedes
produkt drauf gehauen haben dann schaut
morgen mal in lucka mini shop vorbei
zwischen 0 und 24 uhr würde mich sehr
freuen und die tafel köln würde das auch
sehr freuen konnte sich diese lincoln
center testing kinder box ab mit ihr zu
dsds
apropos dsds habt ihr mein tik tok
livestream vorgestern gesehen
[Musik]
riesig
ja ich mache schon angefressen
[Musik]
hier sollen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
als klar die ganze
st
[Musik]
das traurige hier rat ist halt auch
wieder auch nicht will es eigentlich gar
nicht sagen aber es ist die wahrheit
man kann sich auch einfach eine
klopapierrolle gerade umschneiden und
alle werden so krass als gucci in serie
monaco dass meine lieben freunde ist
zehn milliarden prozentig die weit ich
weiß ich sagt in jeder episode tik tok
tuesday aber warum packen alle möglichen
lehrer die zeichnungen so blöd dahin auf
diese zettel und dann sagen die mal das
wichtigste erkennt man nicht erkennen
ein versprechen das wort keyboarder rick
spencer was habe ich mir gerade
angeschaut halle lisa da draußen lisa
bedeutet wie liebenswürdig wie erotisch
es wie siegreich die aufmerksam
falls du lisa heißt dann kommen wir mal
was unter dem video und ich werde
irgendeine lisa mit ihrem kommentar dann
an pin
ich habe tatsächlich einmal sondern
plank simulator gespielt mit wie ai das
ist echt schlimm sowas mal mit sandra
machen stünden wir hier oben aber wieder
bock drauf hätte also wenn die
quarantänezeit vorbei ist das andere
nach köln kommen dann mache ich mit ihr
aus
[Musik]
jäger ich kann so ein ding mal 3 meter
weit werfen der unter 1000 meter
[Musik]
ok
ich hätte auch herzlich willkommen zu
einer weiteren episode ich habe keine
ahnung warum ich das ja gerade mache
[Musik]
gerade mal probiert aber ganz schnell
wieder weg für die fans ist es wirklich
so dass ich 100 prozentig die wahrheit
ich weiß nicht sagt er gerade zum
siebzehnten mal im video aber das waren
100 prozentig meine schwester und ich
auch früher also sarah fährst du siehst
hallo liebe grüße nach berlin
dieses tool ist
[Musik]
mach das bitte nicht zu hause
anwalt
[Musik]
das nicht einmal ein einziges mal ohne
auf die fresse zu fliegen und er
schaffte es viermal mit nur einem sprung
[Musik]
alles klar die katze ist definitiv
talentierter als ich weg bin also ich
selbst habe keine 100 jetzt würde ich
nicht vorstellen dass ein hund so direkt
die erste möglichkeit würde als dass sie
irgendwie von universe oder sony oder
warner oder irgendwie man dass sie
würden lebt diese frau da vertrag ist
das ist mein handy jubiläumskönig bisher
bewilligt
ich glaub das war unangenehm ich mir
zeit schwachen an warum kriege ich sowas
auch bei der uk kämpfen
du hast du keinen der hose
nein echt nicht
okay das ist mit abstand das süßeste
kind das ich je gesehen habe kommen wir
nun allerdings auch schon zum letzten
tick tock video für die heutige wieso
desktop tuesday und zwar ist ein video
von einer person die uns zeigt wie man
sich einen wasser macht erst sinn wenn
die mechanik um 236 71 11 ice-strecke
dankeschön für das super tolle tutorial
an der stelle mich heute hier tätig zu
sein ich glaube endet meine lieben
freunde wenn es euch gefallen hat und
was mir gern wieder einen daumen hoch
unter dem video hier da und schreibt mir
euren tik tok namen und in die
kommentare
ich heiße laser luca schaut gern bei mir
vorbei wenn ihr mir eure namen und in
die kommentare schreibt kann es sein
dass ich euch vorbeischaue und eventuell
ein tick tock von euch in die nächste
episode tinc-news hereinkommt und ja
[Musik]